let's talk about your dear friend and
fellow comedic icon Steve Martin or yes
mr. Steve Martin you and he do this very
funny show together hilarious show that
you've been taking around the world was
it when this whole pandemic hit you guys
were in were you in Ireland we were it
was unbelievable we had left you know
was very interesting because we kept
thinking should we cancel this can we
cancel this is like the week before I
think we flew over on March 6 and we
performed the next night in Glasgow
Scotland and the next night we were in
Dublin and after our show I was back to
hotels around 3:00 in the morning
Dublin time and I'm seeing the president
say everyone must you know get out in 24
hours you know of course Trump forgot to
mention not but you have more time if
you're Americans or if you're in Ireland
or the UK he just left that and so we
frantically got out and and that was it
so I got back to LA on the 13th of March
but it was harrowing we were and also we
were it was confusing you know we
questioned whether we should be doing
shows but the government was saying this
time and doctors were saying was time it
was a very strange messaging at that
time part of your act that you do with
Steve is you to really you really go at
each other you're good friends in real
life but you tell these savage jokes
about it I've seen you guys do it
several times and I weep it's so funny
but it's brutal and I was thinking they
must love that in the UK the Irish love
it and the UK love in America sometimes
people say oh that that was a little
mean I was mean that was hurtful and I
would think in Ireland they must have
just gone crazy for it I love it Steve
says of me you know what I love about
performing with Marty no paparazzi
and I'll stay to Steve you look
fantastic
and I guess the secret is that you've
looked 70 since you were 30 people will
come up to him and say Oh big fan Angela
Lansbury so and what happens the Irish
probably sit there and just they love it
they just nod and go like that's right
you know yeah and I have you know my
father's weren't raised to cross Glenn
County Armagh just over the border in
the north my father was very sarcastic
and I think there was even times when I
would do jiminy glick and I think I'm
channeling my father a little bit really
Marty absolutely I have a tape of me
interviewing my father and Marty of
course is taking singing lessons and of
course has no chance at hell of ever
developing into any sort of singing
talent but that's not the point the
point that he's interested and you know
you hear me laughing in the background
was oh that's the way it was done
[Laughter]
cousins
Patrick and Oliver and I sat up you know
my father was born raised in a bar
shorts bar that's still there run by my
aunt Rosaleen and we sat up till about
5:00 in the morning you know you start
off drinking beer and then you switch to
whiskey and we were talking with
families and people would cry and you
know one of those nights and then around
8:30 when I came down the first one very
blurry eyed and uncle paddy was my
brother and father's brother was
cleaning out the glasses and he just
looked at me said and how did the
character assassination go last night
bar and it's in the genes we still do it
I mean yeah what in this country for a
hundred and twenty years and all we want
to do is sit around and talk treason
about each other and how much do I love
insulting you you look like mr. Rogers
if mr. Rogers drank before each show
[Laughter]
everyone said you that whatever cosmetic
surgery you'd had and you clearly had a
lot 20% more and I think you're done I'm
wishing it had all the work that we all
know I need to get done I wish I had had
it done just before this quarantine
because we get where the facemask I was
thinking the same thing about yourself
or about me about you yes be honest with
me Marty if I went and I got crazy stuff
done
I mean I'm crazy I feel like you would
in front of everybody would you call me
out on her or would you let it go no you
see in that case I wouldn't say a thing
I'd say boy someone got a good night's
sleep
[Laughter]
cosmetic surgery does not work in a man
can you get this look who's that 37 year
old dude right it was a seven year old
who's been in a fire that's also the
problem is it's the same face when you
get bad news oh did you hear so and so's
mother died it's the same face that you
stuck with I'm gonna get tons of work
done during this quarantine tons they're
gonna huge sections of me so you're
gonna go to that which is a full
Hospital yes yeah I have a whole wing of
the house that's just just and their
surgeon standing by and they're gonna go
to town to bring the PO you go to
Conan's house it and and he'll say would
you like a beer would you like an IV
drip I mean it's just naturally you can
have medical information going on
because of your cosmetic needs